I spoke with Julia Lurie the day that she tried something new with her students. She teaches English at an all-girls high school in South Korea, in the city of Gwangju. I reached her on Skype. And she told me that ever since she arrived in South Korea, she'd been really surprised by a bunch of things at her school.
我在朱莉娅·卢里（Julia Lurie）尝试给学生做新课的那天采访了她。她在韩国光州市的一所女子高中教英语。我通过Skype联系上了她。她告诉我，自从来到韩国后，学校里的很多事情都让她感到非常惊讶。
There's a full-length mirror and a scale on every single floor of the school in the main hallway.
学校每一层的走廊里都放着一面全身镜和一个体重秤。
And do girls use them?
女孩们会用吗？
Yeah, they use them all the time. A lot of them don't really think twice about it. And then I asked some of the girls about it, and they said, yeah, our principal wants them there because it's an all-girls high school, and he wants us to be skinny. And he made a joke that if we lose a certain amount of weight, then we can get a cafe. And my first response was like,  OK, that's really messed up. My second response was just, that's really mixed messages.
会，她们一直在用。很多人对此习以为常。后来我问了一些女孩，她们说，是的，校长希望那里有这些东西，因为这是一所女子高中，他希望我们保持苗条。他还开玩笑说，如果我们减掉一定数量的体重，就可以开一家咖啡馆。我的第一反应是：好吧，这真是太糟糕了。我的第二个反应是：这传达的信息太混乱了。
Plastic surgery is super, super common. Like, one in five women in Seoul have it. A lot of my students want to get it after they finish their college entrance exams, as like a rewards of sorts.
整形手术非常非常普遍。在首尔，每五名女性中就有一人整过形。我的许多学生在大学入学考试结束后，都想把它当作一种奖励。
Is this plastic surgery to look more Western?
这种整形手术是为了看起来更像西方人吗？
Yeah, exactly. So the most common is the-- it's called double eyelid surgery. But it's basically to put a crease in your eyelids so it looks like more Western eyelids. Other common ones are cutting down your jaw bones so that you have more a V-shaped face as opposed to a circular face.
是的，完全正确。最常见的是双眼皮手术。但基本上就是要在眼睑上弄出一道褶皱，看起来像西方的眼睑。其他常见的手术还有削下颌骨，这样脸型会更偏向V字脸，而不是圆脸。
In class and on the bus, young women carry these hand mirrors, Julia says, big hand mirrors, like the size of a small dinner plate. And they're always pulling them out and checking themselves. Julia says the pressure on them to look a certain way is worse than in the United States.
朱莉娅说，在课堂上和公交车上，年轻女性都会带着这些手镜，大大的手镜，像小餐盘那么大。她们总是拿出来照自己。朱莉娅说，她们面临的外貌压力比在美国还要大。
When you are applying for university or you're applying for a job here, you put a picture of yourself on your resume or your application. And it is sort of taken for granted that how you look will often go into the decision of if you get into that university or if you get that job.
当你在韩国申请大学或工作时，简历或申请表上要放一张自己的照片。人们理所当然地认为，你的长相往往会影响你是否能被那所大学录取或是否能得到那份工作。
Really? If you get into university, they'll decide based on how pretty you are?
真的吗？如果考大学，他们会根据你长得漂不漂亮来决定？
Well, so I've had it explained to me as, if they have two equal candidates, like otherwise equal candidates, then the prettier person will get the job.
嗯，有人向我解释说，如果她们有两个条件相当的候选人，那么更漂亮的那个人会得到这份工作。
And her students just see this is as normal, like there's nothing weird or disturbing about that at all. And so she wanted to talk to them about it, though she wanted to be careful how she did this. It would be easy to come off as condescending or preachy, or like, oh, this is so terrible. And she didn't want to do that. She just wanted them to know it's not like this everywhere. You could see all this differently. She recorded the class on her iPhone for us. She started with the basics.
而她的学生觉得这是正常的，并没有什么奇怪或令人不安的地方。所以她想和她们谈谈这件事，尽管她想小心行事。很容易显得居高临下或说教，或者让人觉得“噢，这太可怕了”。她不想那样做。她只是想让她们知道，并非到处都是这样。你可以从不同的角度看待这一切。她用iPhone录下了这一课。她从最基础的内容开始。
Not ugly. OK, so raise your hand. Tell me, how does a beautiful woman look?
不是丑。好了，请举手。告诉我，美女长什么样？
White.
白。
White skin.
白皮肤。
White skin. What else?
白皮肤。还有呢？
Me.
我。
Big eyes.
大眼睛。
It's me.
是我。
You!
你！
I don't know if you could hear it, one of the girls said "me" when asked what a beautiful woman looks like.
不知道你们有没有听到，当被问到美女长什么样时，其中一个女孩说了“我”。
So I got "thin," "tall," "V-shaped face." We had this funny moment where they didn't know the word for "breasts," so I was teaching them  the word for "breast."
所以我得到了“瘦”、“高”、“V字脸”这些回答。我们当时有个有趣的时刻，她们不知道“乳房”（breasts）这个词，所以我当时在教她们这个词。
[INAUDIBLE]. No, breast.
[听不清]。不，是乳房。
A breast.
一个乳房。
Breast.
乳房。
A breast.
一个乳房。
OK, so--
好的，那么——
So I'm drawing one on the board.
所以我正在黑板上画一个。
B cup?
B罩杯？
C cup.
C罩杯。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
A cup.
A罩杯。
They talked about how these ideas of beauty are subjective, which definitely was not news to these students. And then Julia explained some of the things that just surprised her as an American living in South Korea. That's how she put it. She wanted to sound as neutral as possible. This is just different than what she'd seen in America. We usually don't have scales and mirrors in high school hallways. We don't use photos on university and job applications the way Koreans do.
她们讨论了这些关于美的观念是主观的，这对学生们来说绝对不是什么新闻。然后朱莉娅解释了一些作为一名在韩国生活的美国人让她感到惊讶的事情。她是这么说的。她想尽可能表现得中立。这和她在美国家乡看到的不同。我们通常不会在高中走廊里放体重秤和镜子。我们也不会像韩国人那样在大学和工作申请表上使用照片。
Photo, OK. In the USA, it is illegal, against the law--
照片，好吧。在美国，这是非法的，违反法律的——
The law.
法律。
--to discriminate, to say no to a person because of how they look.
——因为长相而歧视或拒绝一个人是违法的。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
So I cannot say, [INAUDIBLE], you cannot work for me because you are ugly.
所以我不能说，[听不清]，你不能为我工作，因为你长得丑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Technically, actually, this isn't true. Ugly people are not a protected group under United States law. But you get her point. Ugliness is not going to keep you out of Harvard. Julia showed them a graph so they could see how much plastic surgery women in South Korea get compared to women in other countries. They are number one, more per capita than anywhere. And they discussed all this. One girl said that that statistic made her feel ashamed as a South Korean.
严格来说，这其实不准确。在美国法律下，丑陋的人群不是一个受保护的群体。但你明白她的意思。长得丑并不会让你被哈佛拒之门外。朱莉娅给她们看了一张图表，这样她们就能看到韩国女性的整形手术数量与其他国家女性的对比。她们排在第一位，人均手术量比任何地方都多。她们讨论了这一切。一个女孩说，这个统计数据让她作为一个韩国人感到羞愧。
And toward the end of the class, Julia asked them to write a couple sentences about self-improvement through plastic surgery, or scales in school hallways, or pictures on resumes, about why they were good or why they were bad. And about half of them thought good and half thought bad. Two of Julia's students surprised her by saying that they'd already had plastic surgery themselves. One of them wrote that it was good for her because it gave her confidence.
在快下课时，朱莉娅让她们写了几句话，关于通过整形手术来改善自我，或者学校走廊里的体重秤，或者简历上的照片，写写它们为什么好或为什么坏。大约一半的人认为好，一半认为坏。朱莉娅的两名学生说她们自己已经做过整形手术了，这让她感到惊讶。其中一个写道，这对她来说是件好事，因为它给了她自信。
And the thing is, this is coming from my smartest class. And it was kind of hard to hear-- like, for scales, for example. Now that they're in high school, they're basically like, I like being able to check my weight and seeing if I should eat less or not. And they made the point-- and it's a really valid one-- that they want to make sure they're on track and not be stressing about it.
问题是，这是我最聪明的班级所给出的反应。听到这些有点难受——比如体重秤，现在她们上高中了，她们基本上就是说，我喜欢能够检查体重，看看我是不是该少吃点。她们提出了一个观点——而且是一个非常有效的观点——她们想确保自己没有失控，不必为此感到压力。
It's interesting how much of their argument is, I want to be a success, and this is the way to success.
有趣的是，她们的论点中有很大一部分是：我想成功，而这就是成功的途径。
Mm-hm. It's very utilitarian. It just makes a lot of sense. I can imagine being here, growing up here, and just if this was one of the things that you had to do to succeed and do well, I'm sure I would consider it, too.
嗯。这非常功利。这确实很有道理。我可以想象，如果我在这里出生、在这里长大，如果这是你为了成功和做得好必须做的事情之一，我相信我也会考虑的。
Who learned more today, you or them?
今天谁学到的更多，你还是她们？
I don't know. I was just gonna say, I think I went into this lesson being like, OK, just really, really try to be objective, or seem objective, and walked out of it being like, OK, they have very legit reasons for doing these things.
我不知道。我本来想说，我开始上这节课时心想：好吧，真的真的要试着保持客观，或者看起来客观。走出教室时却心想：好吧，她们做这些事情有非常正当的理由。
Did you learn anything today?
你今天学到什么了吗？
Yes.
学到了。
What did you learn?
你学到了什么？
We are beautiful girls.
我们是美丽的女孩。
I think you are beautiful girls. I agree.
我觉得你们是美丽的女孩。我同意。
Well, today on our radio show, it's the start of a new year. People are making resolutions. We have stories of people's self-improvement schemes-- yes, starting with the defense of teenage girls getting plastic surgery. I know, typical public radio political correctness, a defense of Asian teenagers getting plastic surgery to look white. Some of these schemes on today's show you may agree with, some you may not agree with. We have one that is about an entire nation going on a self-improvement kick. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Get off that treadmill, put down that celery stick, stop reorganizing your budget for the year, and stay with us.
今天在我们的电台节目里，这是新的一年开始。人们正在制定新年计划。我们有关于人们改善自我计划的故事——是的，从为少女进行整形手术辩护开始。我知道，这是典型的公共广播政治正确，为亚洲少女进行整形手术以看起来像白人辩护。今天节目中的一些计划你可能会同意，一些你可能不会。我们有一个关于整个国家致力于自我提升的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。从跑步机上下来，放下那根芹菜，停止为新的一年重新规划你的预算，和我们待在一起。
Act One, Is that a Compass, a Map, a Toothbrush and a Bottle of Purell in Your Pocket, or Are You Just Happy To See Me? Elna Baker has this story of somebody taking the reins and daring to start over, to change his own life.
第一幕：你的口袋里那是指南针、地图、牙刷和一瓶免洗洗手液，还是因为见到我太高兴了？埃尔纳·贝克（Elna Baker）讲述了一个人接过缰绳，敢于重新开始，改变自己生活的故事。
I went to NYU with a guy named Daryl Watson. Unlike a lot of the other students, Daryl didn't come from money. He was there on a scholarship. And instead of partying or doing drugs, he spent his time writing plays, good plays. We kept in touch after college, but I hadn't heard from him in a little while, when in August 2009, I got the kind of email that's generally a cause for concern.
我和一个叫达里尔·沃森（Daryl Watson）的家伙一起在纽约大学上学。和许多其他学生不同，达里尔并没有钱。他是靠奖学金在那里的。他没有去参加聚会或吸毒，而是花时间写剧本，写的还是好剧本。大学毕业后我们保持着联系，但我已经有一段时间没听到他的消息了。直到2009年8月，我收到了一封通常会让人担心的邮件。
It said, "Hello, everyone, I'm writing to let you know that tomorrow I will be undertaking a pilgrimage for peace, walking across the country from Cape Henlopen State Park in Delaware to San Francisco, California. I'll no longer be using this email address or the name 'Daryl Watson.' For the duration of this pilgrimage, I will carry the title carried by my predecessor, 'Peace Pilgrim.' My peace and love go out to you all."
邮件写道：“大家好，我写这封信是想告诉你们，明天我将进行一次和平朝圣之旅，从特拉华州的亨洛彭角州立公园步行穿越整个国家，前往加利福尼亚州的旧金山。我将不再使用这个电子邮件地址或‘达里尔·沃森’这个名字。在这次朝圣期间，我将承载我前任的头衔——‘和平行者’。我向大家致以和平与爱。”
Daryl's walk for peace across the entire country was supposed to take at least six months. Three days later, he posted an update on his blog. All it said was, "Peace Pilgrim down. Repeat, Peace Pilgrim down." I remember thinking, three days? That's it? What happened? I'd never gotten the story, so a month ago I called him and we met up.
达里尔步行穿越整个国家的和平之旅本应至少需要六个月。三天后，他在博客上更新了状态。上面只写着：“和平行者倒下了。重复，和平行者倒下了。”我记得当时想，三天？就这样？发生了什么？我一直没得到答案，所以一个月前我打电话给他，我们见了面。
Oh, I haven't seen you in years. And now all of a sudden we're in a radio station.
噢，我已经好几年没见过你了。现在我们突然在广播电台见面了。
I know. It's like the most official way to see someone.
我知道。这就像见到某人最正式的方式。
He told me the back story. In 2007, Daryl was living in New York City and working at a children's TV show. That part I knew. His career was going well. What I didn't know is that he was also sort of falling apart. He'd been a devout Christian as a teenager. He'd even considered becoming a minister. But he'd left the church, and now, five years later, every night he was having these vivid dreams where people would talk to him about who we was, what his purpose was on earth, the meaning of life. He'd wake up confused and upset and exhausted.
他告诉我背后的故事。2007年，达里尔住在纽约市，在一家儿童电视节目组工作。那部分我了解。他的事业很顺利。我不知道的是，他也快崩溃了。他青少年时期是一名虔诚的基督徒。他甚至考虑过成为一名牧师。但他离开了教会，五年后，他每晚都会做这些生动的梦，梦见人们和他讨论他到底是谁，他在地球上的目的是什么，生命的意义是什么。他醒来时感到困惑、难过且精疲力竭。
The dreams started to preoccupy him during the day. They seemed more important than his waking life, to the point where he almost couldn't function.
这些梦开始在白天占据他的思绪。它们似乎比他的清醒生活更重要，以至于他几乎无法正常工作。
Because I was wrestling with so much fear and so much doubt, I'd wanted an end to the ambiguity. I wanted my mission statement. You know how every business has a mission statement? You know what I mean? That's what I wanted. Like, you are Daryl Watson, you were born on this day, this is your purpose, this is how you're going to do it.
因为我一直在与太多的恐惧和太多的怀疑作斗争，我想终结这种不确定性。我想要我的使命宣言。你知道每家企业都有使命宣言吗？你明白我的意思吗？那就是我想要的。就像是：你是达里尔·沃森，你出生在这一天，这是你的目标，这是你将要实现它的方式。
All the dreams made him wonder if he had a spiritual calling that he was avoiding. Daryl wanted to feel a connection to God, a clear, unshakable answer. So he threw his career aside, left New York, and tried all the classics-- silent meditation and fasting for 40 days, a trip to Peru to study under a shaman, a holy trip to Jerusalem. He did this for a year. Nothing helped.
所有的梦让他怀疑自己是否在逃避某种精神召唤。达里尔想感受到与上帝的联系，一种清晰、不可动摇的答案。于是他抛弃了事业，离开纽约，尝试了所有的经典方式——禁语冥想和禁食40天，去秘鲁向萨满学习，去耶路撒冷进行圣洁之旅。他这样做了整整一年。什么都没用。
Finally, when he was just about to give up, he came across the story of Peace Pilgrim. Peace Pilgrim was a woman named Mildred Norman, who became famous in the 1960s in certain circles for walking across the United States and Canada and Mexico with no money or possessions, just a shirt that said "Peace Pilgrim." She followed Jesus' advice, to be like the lilies of the field, to trust that God would provide. She walked for 28 years. Here she is being interviewed in Pensacola in 1977.
最后，当他正要放弃时，他偶然发现了“和平行者”的故事。和平行者是一位名叫米尔德里德·诺曼（Mildred Norman）的女性，她在20世纪60年代在某些圈子里声名鹊起，因为她徒步穿越了美国、加拿大和墨西哥，没有钱也没有财产，只穿了一件印着“和平行者”的衬衫。她遵循耶稣的建议，像田野里的百合花一样，相信上帝会供养。她走了28年。这是她在1977年彭萨科拉接受采访时的录音。
I haven't got any money, and I don't even accept any money, and I don't belong to any organization, and I don't own anything except what you see. This is me and my only earthly possessions sitting in this chair. I walk until given shelter, fast until given food. I don't even ask. It's given without asking.
我没钱，我甚至不接受任何钱，我不属于任何组织，我除了你们看到的这些以外什么都不拥有。这就是我，除了坐在椅子上的这些，是我唯一的世俗财产。我走，直到获得遮蔽处；我禁食，直到获得食物。我甚至不问。它们会在不要求的情况下被给予。
I didn't know why other people weren't doing it.
我不知道为什么其他人不这么做。
Peace Pilgrim's story had all the answers Daryl was looking for. She trusted God and it worked. God did provide for her, for almost 30 years. She had the unambiguous connection to God that Daryl desperately wanted. She had no doubt or fear, and her fearlessness inspired others.
和平行者的故事拥有达里尔想要的所有答案。她信任上帝，而且奏效了。上帝确实供养了她近30年。她与上帝有着达里尔迫切渴望的那种明确的连接。她没有怀疑或恐惧，她的无畏鼓舞了别人。
I thought, why aren't more people giving away everything that they own and walking across the country? Of course, this is what you do. When you live in this world, as crazy as it is, this is what you do.
我想，为什么更多的人不放弃他们拥有的一切并步行穿越这个国家呢？当然，这就是你应该做的。当你活在这个世界上，尽管它很疯狂，但这就是你应该做的。
So in August of 2009, Daryl decided to become today's Peace Pilgrim. He bought a blue t-shirt and spray-painted "Peace Pilgrim" across the front and "Walking Coast to Coast for Peace" on the back. Then he shaved his hair and his beard. After that, he cleared out his bank accounts and credit cards, putting all the money into an envelope he planned to give to charity. Lastly, he tore up his driver's license.
所以2009年8月，达里尔决定成为当代的和平行者。他买了一件蓝色T恤，在前面喷漆写上“和平行者”，在背面写上“为和平徒步横跨海岸”。然后他剃光了头发和胡须。之后，他清空了银行账户和信用卡，把所有的钱都放进一个信封里，打算捐给慈善机构。最后，他撕掉了驾驶执照。
Just 10 days after first getting the idea, Daryl caught a bus to Delaware. That night, from a motel in Cape Henlopen, he sent the infamous mass email and then wiped his computer clean of files, including, shockingly, all the plays he'd written over the last eight years. He left his computer, phone, and iPod in the motel room, with a note for the cleaning staff to keep them. The next morning, August 30, Daryl began his walk.
仅仅在产生这个想法的10天后，达里尔就搭上了一辆去特拉华州的巴士。那天晚上，在亨洛彭角的一家汽车旅馆里，他发出了那封臭名昭著的群发邮件，然后清除了电脑里的文件，令人震惊的是，包括他过去八年写的所有剧本。他把电脑、手机和iPod留在旅馆房间里，给清洁人员留了一张便条让他们收下。第二天早上，8月30日，达里尔开始了徒步之旅。
He'd do what the original Peace Pilgrim did, trust that people would be moved by his faith in God and provide for him. So the only things in his pockets were a compass, a map, a toothbrush, and a bottle of Purell. No food, no sleeping bag, not even a coat. The first thing he wanted to do was give away the envelope with all his money, roughly $2,000.
他要像最初的和平行者那样做，相信人们会被他对上帝的信仰所感动并帮助他。所以他口袋里只有指南针、地图、牙刷和一瓶免洗洗手液。没有食物，没有睡袋，甚至没有外套。他想做的第一件事就是送出那个装着他所有钱的信封，大约2000美元。
That first night, I walked by a church and I thought, well, maybe I can give the money to whoever's at this church. And so there's a pastor there. And he and I start talking. And I try to give him this envelope full of money, and he gets a really suspicious look on his face. And he doesn't come right out and say it, but I think he probably thought that I stole it, because it's a good deal of money in an envelope. And he looked at it. I kind of laughed. I was like, oh, no, I didn't steal this. I withdrew it. Like, I withdrew all the money from my bank account. That's where I got the money. Do you want it?
第一天晚上，我走过一个教堂，我想，也许我可以把钱给这个教堂的人。于是那里有一位牧师。他和我开始交谈。我试着给他那个装满钱的信封，他脸上露出了一种非常怀疑的神情。他没有直接说出来，但我认为他可能以为我偷了这些钱，因为信封里有一笔不少的钱。他看着它。我笑了笑。我说，哦不，我没偷这些。我取出来的。就像我从我的银行账户里取出了所有的钱。这就是我钱的来源。你想要吗？
Something to know, the original Peace Pilgrim was a sweet-faced older white lady who started walking in the 1950s. Daryl is a tall, athletic 30-year-old black man walking in 2009. The pastor's reaction surprised him, but didn't shock him.
要知道，最初的和平行者是一位面容慈祥的年长白人女性，她在20世纪50年代开始徒步。达里尔是一个身材高大、运动型的30岁黑人男子，他在2009年徒步。牧师的反应让他感到意外，但没有让他震惊。
I wasn't like, oh my goodness, why would he think that I stole this? I think it was a reasonable suspicion regardless of what color I was, but I don't think being black helped. I was annoyed. But then I was like, well, maybe this is a chance for me to spread the message. You know what I mean? So then he and I started talking. And I told him why I was doing what I was doing. And he said, well, you know the only way to peace is really through Jesus.
我没有那种“天哪，他为什么会认为我偷了钱”的感觉。我认为这是一个合理的怀疑，无论我是什么肤色，但我认为我是黑人对此没什么帮助。我很恼火。但后来我想，也许这是一个让我传播信息的机会。你明白我的意思吗？所以我和他开始谈话。我告诉他我为什么要这样做。他说，你知道，通往和平的唯一途径确实是通过耶稣。
And I was like, I understand what you're saying. I used to believe that myself. I disagree. And he was like, you're wrong. And I got into a sort of heated theological debate. And then, finally, I was like, well, maybe I should just be on my way. And he's like, you know what, I'm not gonna take your money. I think he was going to take the money. He actually was holding the envelope as he was debating with me. And then at a certain point, he was like, you know what, I'm not gonna take this money, because I feel like to take it from you, who's not a believer, would be sending the wrong message.
我说，我明白你在说什么。我曾经也那样相信过。但我不同意。他说，你错了。我陷入了一场有些激烈的神学辩论。最后，我说，好吧，也许我该上路了。他说，你知道吗，我不会拿你的钱。我想他本来是要拿那笔钱的。他在和我辩论时确实一直拿着那个信封。然后在某个时刻，他说，你知道吗，我不会要这笔钱，因为我觉得从你这个非信徒手里拿走它，会传达错误的信息。
And then he said, Jesus said to the disciples, if you go into a town and you try to spread the gospel and they don't hear you, leave that town and then wipe the dirt off your feet. And let that be a testimony to that place. And he said, so I wipe my feet off at you. And that really bothered me.
然后他说，耶稣对门徒说，如果你走进一个城镇，试图传播福音而他们不听，那就离开那个城镇，然后掸掉脚上的灰尘。让那成为那个地方的见证。他说，所以我对你掸掉我脚上的灰尘。这真的让我很难受。
But Daryl couldn't dwell on it. He still had to get rid of the money and find a place to sleep. So he wrote "for charity" on the envelope and dropped it in the first mailbox he saw. Without any offers to stay inside, Daryl slept on the steps of the Catholic Church that night.
但达里尔无法沉浸在其中。他还得处理掉那些钱并找个睡觉的地方。所以他在信封上写下“捐给慈善机构”，然后把它投进了他看到的第一个邮箱里。没有获得留在室内的邀请，达里尔那天晚上睡在天主教堂的台阶上。
You know, it was just starting to get cold out. I didn't have a coat. I didn't have a sleeping bag. I didn't have really anything. And it was just concrete. And concrete is really cold. So that first night, I barely slept at all. And the second day, I walked into this college town. And I made it to some sort of fast food restaurant place. I stopped a lot at fast food places, because they let you have water for free. And then I would just sit there and just try to recover.
你知道，外面刚开始变冷。我没有外套。我没有睡袋。我基本上什么都没有。而那只是混凝土。混凝土真的非常冷。所以那天晚上，我几乎没怎么睡。第二天，我走进了这个大学城。我到了某家快餐店之类的地方。我经常在快餐店停留，因为他们让你免费喝水。然后我就会坐在那儿，试着恢复体力。
And this college kid saw my Peace Pilgrim shirt, and so he came over and started talking to me. And he's like, that's really crazy that you're doing this. Have you done anything like this before? And I was like, no. He's like, have you ever hiked long distance or walked long distance like this? I was like, no. He was like, hmm. He's like, you don't have any supplies or any food, anything like that?
有个大学生看到了我的“和平行者”衬衫，所以他走过来开始和我聊天。他说，你做这件事真的很疯狂。你以前做过这样的事吗？我说，没有。他说，你以前有没有进行过长途跋涉或像这样长距离步行？我说，没有。他说，嗯。他说，你没有任何补给或食物，像那样的东西？
And I said, I'm not worried about it. I think I'm just sort of trusting in God's providence to get me through. And he's like, well, you're definitely going to freeze. And he's like, I don't know what God's gonna help you do in the cold, because it's starting to drop. He's like, and once you hit the Midwest, there's gonna be  snow. He's like, and you don't have anything. And he was wearing a sweatshirt, this red sweatshirt. And he took it off and he gave it to me.
我说，我不担心这个。我想我只是在某种程度上相信上帝的眷顾会让我渡过难关。他说，好吧，你肯定会被冻坏的。他说，我不知道上帝会如何帮你抵御寒冷，因为气温开始下降了。他说，一旦你到了中西部，就会下雪。他说，你什么都没有。他穿着一件运动衫，那件红色的运动衫。他脱下来给了我。
Wow.
哇。
And he was like, here. He's like, you're going to need this more than I am. And he was right, because that night, I think it was even colder than the night before. And there was a definite wind.
他说，拿着吧。他说，你会比我更需要它。他是对的，因为那天晚上，我想比前一天晚上更冷。而且有明显的风。
By the end of day two, in a college town of all places, Daryl still hadn't been offered a crash pad. So he found a baseball field on campus with a dugout, and rolled himself like a burrito into a slab of AstroTurf. It was still cold, but he managed to get some rest. On day three, approximately 40 miles in, Daryl crossed his first state line into Maryland. It was a triumph. He'd walked across an entire state. Granted, it was Delaware, but still.
到了第二天结束时，在这样一个大学城里，达里尔还是没有被邀请到任何地方休息。所以他在校园里找到了一个带休息区的棒球场，把自己像墨西哥卷饼一样裹在一块人造草坪里。天气依然很冷，但他设法休息了一下。第三天，走了大约40英里后，达里尔越过了他第一个州界，进入了马里兰州。这是一个胜利。他已经走过了一个完整的州。好吧，那是特拉华州，但仍然算。
Now his route took him into a rural area, which meant fewer cars and fewer people to stop and talk with. Feeling incredibly alone, he tried to keep his mind on God, like Peace Pilgrim had, and to give up his fear. But oddly, things were working the other way around for him. He'd entered the journey fearlessly, and only along the way was he beginning to understand how many things there were to fear.
现在他的路线带他进入了一个乡村地区，这意味着更少的汽车和更少可以交谈的人。感到异常孤独，他试着像和平行者那样，让思绪专注于上帝，放下恐惧。但奇怪的是，情况对他来说却是反着来的。他无所畏惧地开始了旅程，却在途中才开始意识到有那么多东西是需要恐惧的。
I finally got to a point where I just couldn't walk anymore. And there was still daylight out. And I'd wanted to walk all day, but I just didn't have the strength.
我终于到了一个走不动了的地步。而外面还是白天。我本想走一整天，但我实在没有力气了。
Too tired to go any further, Daryl found another church, but it was locked. So he laid down in a covered concrete area behind it.
太累了无法再往前走，达里尔找到了另一个教堂，但门锁着。所以他躺在教堂后面一个带遮蔽的混凝土区域。
And I drift off to sleep for, like, a moment, and then suddenly I feel this warmth enter my body. And all of a sudden, I have all this energy. And I hear a voice inside of me say, you gotta get up and you need to start walking right now or you are going to freeze to death. And I got up and I started walking. And after I got that second wind and I got to a playground, there was a slide that had a little house at the top. So I was like, ah, shelter. And I climbed in, and it was metal and wet inside. But I still tried anyway, just because it was at least protecting me from the wind.
我睡着了片刻，然后突然感觉到一种温暖进入我的身体。突然间，我充满了精力。我听到内心的声音说，你必须起来，你现在需要开始走，否则你会被冻死。我站起来开始走。在我恢复体力并走到一个操场后，那里有一个滑梯，顶部有个小房子。所以我心想，啊，遮蔽处。我爬了进去，里面是金属做的而且潮湿。但我还是尝试了，仅仅因为它至少保护我不受风吹。
And it looked like a tiny house.
而且它看起来像个小房子。
And it looked like a tiny house. And I start to drift off a little bit, and I felt that same voice kind of kick in and say, you got to get out of here. Leave. And sure, I had a moment where I was like, oh, is this God? Is this an angel? In the moment, I was like, whatever it is, it might have a point. I may need to get up and start walking. And maybe I can work out the psychological, theological questions later.
而且它看起来像个小房子。我开始有点睡着了，我感到同样的声音再次响起说，你必须离开这里。离开。当然，我有那么一刻心想：噢，这是上帝吗？这是天使吗？在那一刻，我想：不管是什麽，它可能有道理。我可能需要起来开始走。也许我可以以后再处理那些心理和神学问题。
So I got up, and I was just walking and walking and walking, trying to make it to the next town. And at one point, a police car pulled up behind me and started flashing his lights. And I got so happy, because I thought, maybe he'll take me to jail and I'll get to sleep inside of a warm place. And the cop got out, because I was walking on the highway. And he was like, what are you doing? He's like, it's kind of late to be out for a walk, isn't it?
所以我站起来，不停地走啊走，试图到达下一个城镇。在某个时刻，一辆警车停在我身后，闪烁着灯光。我非常高兴，因为我想，也许他会把我带到监狱，我能在温暖的地方睡觉。警察走下车，因为我在高速公路上走。他说，你在做什么？他说，这么晚出来散步是不是有点太晚了？
It was in the middle of the night.
那是在半夜。
It was, like, 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning. I told him what I was doing, that I was on a pilgrimage for peace. And he was like, OK, do you mind if I take a look inside your bag? I had a bag that a woman had given me, and I was using it to carry what little food I had. So I gave it to him. He looked through it. He gave it back to me. And he was like, OK, you're free to go.
大约是凌晨1点或2点。我告诉他我在做什么，我在进行和平朝圣。他说，好的，你介意我检查一下你的包吗？我有一个女人给我的包，我用它来装我仅有的一点食物。所以我给了他。他翻看了它。他又把它还给我。他说，好的，你可以走了。
And I said, do you mind if I sit in the back of your car and just get warm for a little bit? Because man, when  he opened the car door, I could feel the warmth inside of the car, and I wanted to be in there so badly. And I asked him. And he had a police dog in the back that was looking at me. And he said, I don't mind, but I think he would. And he pointed to the dog.
我说，你介意我坐在你的车后座，稍微暖和一下吗？因为伙计，当他打开车门时，我能感觉到车内的温暖，我太想待在那儿了。我问他。他后座有一条警犬正看着我。他说，我不介意，但我认为它会介意。他指了指那条狗。
So the cop drives off, and I walk for probably another 30 minutes. And I'm tired, I'm hungry, my feet are killing me, I'm really thirsty, I'm freezing. And I saw this billboard. And it said, it's OK to make mistakes as long as they're new ones. And I was like, hmm, I wonder if I made a mistake. And it didn't quite sink in yet, which is funny because maybe I like to think that, for someone who'd been wanting messages about what to do and what not to do, that God was like, let me give him a billboard.
于是警察开车走了，我又走了大概30分钟。我很累，很饿，脚疼得要命，非常口渴，快冻僵了。我看到了一个广告牌。上面写着：犯错没关系，只要是新错误就行。我心想，嗯，不知道我是否犯了一个错误。它还没完全沉淀下来，这很有趣，因为也许我喜欢这样想：对于一个一直想要关于怎么做和不怎么做的指引的人来说，上帝就像是：让他看个广告牌吧。
What is that billboard even for?
那个广告牌到底是干什么用的？
It makes me wonder now if that billboard even existed and it wasn't just a hallucination. I'm pretty sure that it existed. But who knows. Who knows, man.
这让我现在怀疑那个广告牌是否真的存在，而不是只是我的幻觉。我非常确定它是存在的。但谁知道呢。谁知道呢，伙计。
From the highway, Daryl could see the lights of a Best Western. He took the next exit and walked to the hotel. He got lucky. The woman working in the night shift was nice and let him sit in the lobby and warm up for a few hours. But then her manager showed up.
从高速公路上，达里尔可以看到最佳西方酒店的灯光。他从下一个出口离开，走到了旅馆。他很幸运。在夜班工作的女人人很好，让他坐在大厅里暖和了几个小时。但后来她的经理出现了。
He's looking at me, and he doesn't know who I am. He knows I'm not a guest. He knows that I've eaten food, that I've used the bathroom. He's got his eye on me.
他看着我，但他不知道我是谁。他知道我不是客人。他知道我吃了食物，用了洗手间。他一直盯着我。
Daryl didn't want any trouble from the manager, so he left and went across the street to a fast food place, where he sat with his usual cup of water. He thought about the original Peace Pilgrim and felt embarrassed. She'd walked 25 miles a day in three different countries for 28 years. He'd made it to Denton, Maryland, and was done in after three days.
达里尔不想给经理带来麻烦，所以他离开了，走到街对面的快餐店，坐在那里喝着他通常的那杯水。他想到了最初的和平行者，感到很尴尬。她28年来在三个不同国家每天走25英里。他走到马里兰州的登顿，三天后就彻底不行了。
Daryl saw that he hadn't had anywhere near enough respect for what she'd accomplished. He couldn't walk anymore, and he knew it. And with no money, no phone, no ID, he realized that he had only one option in the vicinity for getting rescued. So he went back to the Best Western and the suspicious manager.
达里尔意识到他对她所取得的成就缺乏足够的尊重。他不能再走了，他心里清楚。而且没有钱、没有手机、没有身份证，他意识到他在附近只有一种获救的选择。于是他回到了最佳西方酒店和那个多疑的经理那里。
I opened with, I have made a huge mistake. And then I just started telling him everything that had happened. I was crying. I told him, I was like, this is my shirt that I've made. It says "Peace Pilgrim" on it. And I showed him the back, which had "Walking Coast to Coast for Peace." I started in Delaware, I made it here, and I'm completely exhausted and hungry. And I don't think I can walk another step.
我开场白说：我犯了一个大错。然后我就开始告诉他所有发生过的事情。我在哭。我告诉他，我说，这是我做的衬衫。上面写着“和平行者”。我给他看了背面，上面写着“为和平徒步横跨海岸”。我从特拉华州出发，走到了这儿，我完全精疲力竭而且饥饿。我不认为我能再走一步了。
And he was like, well, do you need me to call Social Services or something like that? And I was like, no, I think I need to-- if I could just-- can I make a phone call?
他说，那么，你需要我打电话给社会服务部之类的地方吗？我说，不，我想我需要——如果我可以的话——我能打个电话吗？
Daryl called his mother, who got him a room for the night. Over the phone, she told him, I'm glad you're safe, get some rest, take a nice hot bath. Then he called a friend, who rented a car and started driving down from New York to come get him. Upstairs in his room, Daryl noticed that all the urgency, all the questioning that had driven him for the last couple of years, it was gone.
达里尔给他母亲打了电话，她为他开了一间房休息一晚。在电话里，她说：我很高兴你平安，好好休息一下，洗个热水澡。然后他给一个朋友打了电话，那朋友租了辆车从纽约开车下来接他。在楼上的房间里，达里尔注意到，过去几年驱使他的那种紧迫感、那种质疑，全都消失了。
Probably the culminating moment in all of this was probably sitting in that bathtub and just being so exhausted that I just didn't care anymore if I had the answer. It just wasn't important.
这一切的高潮时刻可能是坐在浴缸里，感到如此疲惫，以至于我根本不在乎自己是否拥有答案。那根本不重要。
He'd left New York more than a year ago. He'd been on this journey, most of it alone and suffering, and trying to figure out the meaning of life. He'd been obsessing over his dreams a year before that. And three days in the cold made him realize he was doing this to himself. He was making himself suffer. And he could stop. Which landed him in the same messy place so many of us are in, not having any answers. So we just ignore the questions and get on with our lives.
他一年前离开纽约。他一直在进行这段旅程，大部分时间是独自一人且饱受折磨，试图找出生命的意义。在此之前的一年里，他一直对那些梦耿耿于怀。而在寒冷中度过的三天让他意识到，他是在折磨自己。他在让自己受苦。而他可以停止。这让他陷入了我们许多人所处的同样混乱的状态：没有任何答案。所以我们只是忽略这些问题，继续过我们的生活。
Daryl's back to writing plays now. It took him a year and a half of heavy lifting to rebuild the life he'd given up. And of all the writing that he worked so hard on and then erased, the one thing that remained was that email. An email, as we all know, lives forever.
达里尔现在又回到了写剧本。他花了整整一年半的苦活才重建了他放弃的生活。在他辛苦工作又删掉的所有作品中，唯一保留下来的是那封邮件。正如我们所知，邮件永远存在。
It may have gone to some executives at Disney. I think it went to my agent at the time. I think it went to a publishing company that had published some of my plays. It went to everybody. And so it's been one of those things that helps remind me that I never want to do that ever again. So if things ever get tough, I never think to myself, well, I could always just give everything away and try to walk across the country. I know not to have that thought, because I've done that, and it didn't work for me.
它可能发给了迪士尼的一些高管。我想它发给了我当时的经纪人。我想它发给了一家出版过我一些剧本的出版公司。它发给了所有人。所以这已成为提醒我永远不想再那样做的事情之一。所以如果事情变得困难，我永远不会对自己想：好吧，我总可以放弃一切，尝试步行穿越整个国家。我知道不能有那个想法，因为我做过，而且那对我没用。
Yeah. Someone once said, it's OK to make mistakes as long as they're new ones.
是啊。有人曾经说过，犯错没关系，只要是新错误就行。
[LAUGHS]. That should be on a billboard.
[笑声]。那应该写在广告牌上。
It should be.
确实应该。
I think. It's that good.
我觉得。它就是那么好。
That story by Elna Baker. She's the author of a book, The New York Regional Mormon Singles Halloween Dance . A theater company in Los Angeles is doing a reading of Daryl Watson's latest play, Unbound , in February. Coming up, Tempest in a TED Talk. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
那个故事来自埃尔纳·贝克。她是《纽约区域摩门教单身万圣节舞会》一书的作者。洛杉矶的一家剧院公司将在二月进行达里尔·沃森最新剧本《解脱》（Unbound）的朗读会。接下来，TED演讲中的风暴。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. The very first time that I ever met my wife-- ever, our first conversation-- she told me that at the time, she'd just started doing yoga, and she had just signed up for an adult education French class. And so I said, so you're on a real self-improvement kick, which I thought was just me listening to what she was saying and making conversation. She thought it was the most condescending possible thing I could have said at that moment. She actually went to her best friend, Debbie, afterwards and they had a whole conversation, apparently, about what an ass I was to have said that.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我第一次见到我妻子的那次——有史以来，我们的第一次谈话——她告诉我，当时她刚开始做瑜伽，并且刚报名参加了一个成人教育法语班。所以我说：所以你正在进行真正的自我提升之旅，我以为我只是在倾听她说的话并进行交流。她认为那是她当时听到的最居高临下的话。事后，她甚至去找了她最好的朋友黛比（Debbie），显然她们就我说了那番话是多么混蛋进行了整场对话。
So I have learned that when you add the word "kick" to the phrase "self-improvement," you just make it sound ridiculous. Though truthfully, the phrase "self-improvement" is always on the verge of sounding ridiculous. Any plan to change your look or to start a new career or reinvent yourself in a new place, the clumsy first steps that you take toward any big goal are inherently awkward and stumbly.
所以我学到，当你给“自我提升”这个词加上“计划”（kick）这个短语时，你只会让它听起来很荒谬。尽管老实说，“自我提升”这个短语总是处于听起来荒谬的边缘。任何改变你外观、开始新职业或在新的地方重塑自我的计划，你迈向任何宏大目标笨拙的第一步，本质上都是尴尬且踉跄的。
Today on our show, for the new year, with people everywhere making resolutions, it's all about people bravely heading out on one self-improvement kick or another. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Some Like it Dot. In this act, we head to a country that tried for a while to build a perfect world, to solve all of their national problems in one swoop. The country is Honduras. Jacob Goldstein and Chana Joffe-Walt tell more.
今天在我们的节目里，在新的一年里，到处都有人在制定决议，这全都关于人们勇敢地踏上一项或另一项自我提升之旅。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕：有些人喜欢点（Some Like it Dot）。在这一幕中，我们前往一个曾经试图建造一个完美世界、试图一举解决所有国家问题的国家。这个国家是洪都拉斯。雅各布·戈德斯坦（Jacob Goldstein）和查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）讲述更多内容。
We went to Honduras in the fall, about a month before their presidential primary. And it felt weirdly a lot like home. The election was everywhere, on news stories, billboards, and of course campaign ads, which were just like the ads we were hearing in the US.
我们在秋天去了洪都拉斯，在他们总统初选前大约一个月。那里感觉奇怪地像家一样。选举无处不在，新闻报道、广告牌，当然还有竞选广告，和我们在美国听到的广告一模一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
This candidate is focused on the future, not the past.
这位候选人专注于未来，而不是过去。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
This guy wants to put the country on the road to unity. And this last candidate, he's a family man who wants you to know that he believes not only in principles, but also in values.
这个人想让国家走上团结之路。而最后这位候选人，他是一位顾家男人，他想让你知道他不仅相信原则，也相信价值观。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And like candidates all over the world, the candidates in Honduras were giving out free stuff to win votes. But here's where the Honduras election started to seem very, very different. The schwag wasn't just bumper stickers and lawn signs. Alberto Arce, a reporter with the Associated Press based in Honduras, says the presidential campaigns showed up at the morgue to give stuff away.
和世界各地的候选人一样，洪都拉斯的候选人也会发放免费物品来赢得选票。但这就是洪都拉斯选举开始显得非常、非常不同的地方。赠品不仅仅是保险杠贴纸和草坪标志。阿联酋通讯社驻洪都拉斯的记者阿尔贝托·阿尔塞（Alberto Arce）表示，总统竞选活动甚至出现在停尸房发放东西。
If you go to the morgue any day at 8:00 in the morning, you will see that there are three cars, like pick-ups, in the door with coffins. But then if you get a closer look, you will see that these cars, these pick-ups with coffins, have banners from political candidates.
如果你在早上8点任何一天去停尸房，你会看到门口有三辆车，比如皮卡车，上面装着棺材。但如果你仔细看，你会发现这些车，这些装着棺材的皮卡车，有政治候选人的横幅。
Political candidates in Honduras are giving away coffins. Honduras has the highest murder rate in the world. And a lot of Hondurans can't afford coffins.
洪都拉斯的政治候选人正在发放棺材。洪都拉斯拥有世界上最高的谋杀率。很多洪都拉斯人买不起棺材。
So the point is that, if you are poor, you go to the morgue and you ask one of these cars, please, can you give me a coffin for my dad or for my brother that has been killed, and they will give it. So everybody knows that they owe the favor to the politician that is giving this favor.
所以重点是，如果你很穷，你去停尸房问这些车其中之一：拜托，你能给我父亲或兄弟一具棺材吗，他们被杀了。他们会给的。所以每个人都知道他们欠了发这些东西的政客一个人情。
That's how you win votes in the world's murder capital, give people a way to bury their loved ones. It's just one weird, dark sign of how bad things are in Honduras. And the leaders of the country know this. Everybody knows this. And everybody knows basically what problems need to be fixed, but it's really hard to figure out where to start.
这就是你在世界谋杀之都赢得选票的方式，给人们一种埋葬亲人的方法。这只是洪都拉斯情况有多糟糕的一个怪异而黑暗的迹象。国家的领导人知道这一点。每个人都知道这一点。而且每个人基本上都知道需要解决什么问题，但真的很难找出从哪里开始。
Say you want to start with the education system. The education system is terrible because teachers are always on strike. Teachers are always on strike because they don't get paid. They don't get paid because the government does a terrible job collecting taxes. Oh, and also because the government doesn't collect taxes, it can't hire a proper police force. And there's a huge backlog in the courts. And Hondurans think their cops, and for that matter, lots of other government workers, can be bought and sold. So you have corruption and chaos and violence.
假设你想从教育系统开始。教育系统很糟糕，因为老师总是罢工。老师总是罢工，因为他们拿不到工资。他们拿不到工资，因为政府在税收征管方面做得非常糟糕。哦，而且因为政府不收税，所以雇不起合适的警察队伍。法院也有巨大的积压。洪都拉斯人认为他们的警察，以及就此而言，许多其他政府工作人员，是可以被买卖的。所以你有腐败、混乱和暴力。
How can you fix this? Where do you start? There is this one radical idea floating around. What if you could just get rid of everything and start from scratch?
你该怎么解决这个问题？你从哪里开始？有一个激进的想法正在流传。如果你能摆脱一切并从头开始呢？
In Honduras, there is one man who really owns this idea, Octavio Sanchez. He's the chief of staff to the current Honduran president. He has an office in the presidential palace. And Octavio has a habit of staring longingly out of the windows of that office. He looks so much the part of a national dreamer, it can feel fabricated. It is not.
在洪都拉斯，有一个人真正拥有这个想法，奥克塔维奥·桑切斯（Octavio Sanchez）。他是现任洪都拉斯总统的幕僚长。他在总统府有一间办公室。奥克塔维奥有一种习惯，会渴望地盯着那间办公室的窗外。他看起来太像一个国家梦想家了，以至于感觉是虚构的。但并不是。
There is something that I don't have here, which is a book that I published when I was 16 years old.
这里有些东西我没有，那是我16岁时出版的一本书。
You published a book when you were 16?
你16岁时出版了一本书？
Yes.
是的。
The book is set in the year 2050. And it's in the form of these imagined bulletins from the Honduran government about how the country solved all its problems. It's this incredibly nerdy book full of youthful idealism.
这本书设定在2050年。它是以洪都拉斯政府如何解决所有问题的想象公报形式呈现的。这真是一本令人难以置信的、充满青春理想主义的呆板书。
In his 20s, Octavio spent hours trying to actually figure out why are some countries rich and some countries poor. He showed us this giant spreadsheet he made with his friends.
20多岁时，奥克塔维奥花了数小时试图找出为什么有些国家富裕，有些国家贫穷。他向我们展示了他和朋友们制作的这个巨大的电子表格。
Wow. So you looked at hundreds of countries?
哇。所以你看了几百个国家？
Yes.
是的。
Can you just read through a little bit of the book?
你能简单读一点这本书吗？
Basically, it gives you an idea of what is the form of government of every country in the world, how that form of government impacts per capita income.
基本上，它让你了解世界上每个国家的政府形式，这种政府形式如何影响人均收入。
Shows measures of inequality, of corruption.
显示了不平等、腐败的衡量标准。
So this is the kind of thing that you put together with your friends when you're hanging out?
所以这就是你和朋友聚在一起时会一起做的东西？
Yes. Basically I don't drink, so it was basically just sitting around to drink a Diet Coke and talk about what we could do.
是的。基本上我不喝酒，所以基本上就是坐在一起喝健怡可乐，谈论我们能做什么。
What were you looking for?
你在找什么？
Answers, basically, to how we can become a developed nation. There's no reason why, 50 years from now, Honduras cannot become a developed country. We were dreaming about this.
基本上，我们如何成为发达国家的答案。50年后，洪都拉斯没有理由不能成为一个发达国家。我们梦想着这个。
Octavio finally got his chance to make big changes for his country in 2002. He became an adviser to the president of Honduras.
2002年，奥克塔维奥终于得到了为国家做出重大改变的机会。他成为了洪都拉斯总统的顾问。
I thought that we could change everything.
我以为我们可以改变一切。
What was the picture that you had in mind?
你脑海中的蓝图是什么样的？
I had a  whole list of all the things that we were gonna do. And I was part of this government that was run by really honest and competent people. And it was incredibly hard to get anything done.
我有一份我们将要做的所有事情的清单。而且我是这个由真正诚实且有能力的人管理的政府的一部分。但要完成任何事情都极其困难。
That list that Octavio had, it had about 20 big reforms on it that all had to happen to really change Honduras. But in the four-year presidential term, Octavio and his colleagues only got two of those things done. They failed at 18.
奥克塔维奥的那份清单上大约有20项重大改革，所有这些都必须实现才能真正改变洪都拉斯。但在四年的总统任期内，奥克塔维奥和他的同事只完成了其中的两项。他们在18项上失败了。
So when Octavio heard about this new big idea for huge change, to start from scratch, he thought it might be the only real solution for Honduras. The idea was this. You take one little corner of the country, and you say, right here, we're going to try an experiment-- get rid of our laws, our police force, all of it. And in this little corner, we're going to start over. Octavio first heard about the idea from a colleague who sat him down and scrawled it out on a piece of paper.
所以当奥克塔维奥听说这个关于巨大变革的大新想法——从头开始——时，他认为这可能是洪都拉斯唯一的真正解决方案。这个想法是这样的。你取国家的一个小角落，说：就在这里，我们要尝试一个实验——摆脱我们的法律、我们的警察队伍，摆脱一切。在这个小角落里，我们要从头开始。奥克塔维奥第一次从一位同事那里听到这个想法，那个人让他坐下并在纸上草草画了出来。
He drew the map of Honduras. And he used to put a period in the middle of that map.
他画了洪都拉斯的地图。他过去常在那张地图中间画一个圆点。
So that's Honduras.
所以那是洪都拉斯。
That's Honduras. And its a really tiny spot in the middle of the map.
那是洪都拉斯。这是一个地图中间非常小的地方。
So you just made a dot in the middle of this?
所以你只是在这个中间画了一个点？
Yes. He kept telling her, no, it's just taking a small space, a really tiny space, and doing all the reforms there. Instead of fighting to do two, three, or four reforms during the life of a government, why don't you just do all of those reforms at once in a really small space? And that's why this idea was appealing. It's really the possibility of turning everything around.
是的。他一直在告诉她：不，这只是占据一个小的空间，一个非常小的空间，并在那里进行所有的改革。与其在一个政府的任期内争斗着进行两项、三项或四项改革，为什么不一次性在非常小的空间内完成所有这些改革呢？这就是这个想法吸引人的原因。这真的是扭转一切的可能性。
For Octavio, this was it. You could deal with everything right there in the dot. Clean slate. New laws, new schools, everything. And when the rest of Honduras saw how well things were going inside the dot, you'd bring those big reforms to the rest of the country.
对于奥克塔维奥来说，就是这个了。你可以在那个点上处理一切。一张白纸。新法律，新学校，一切。当洪都拉斯的其他地方看到那个点里的情况有多好时，你就会把那些重大改革带到国家的其他地方。
The only problem is, this idea is completely crazy. What government of any country looks around and says, you know what the problem is here? Us. Let's just create a new mini-government that looks nothing like us.
唯一的问题是，这个想法完全是疯狂的。任何国家的政府会环顾四周说：你知道这里的问题是什么吗？是我们自己。让我们建立一个新的、看起来一点也不像我们的迷你政府吧。
So Octavio was stuck. No one was interested in his big idea, until a famous economist from a rich country started saying, you know what would be a really good idea?
所以奥克塔维奥被困住了。没人对他的这个大想法感兴趣，直到一位来自富裕国家的著名经济学家开始说：你知道什么会是一个真正的好主意吗？
We should seriously consider building hundreds of brand-new cities, pick a totally uninhabited site and to say, we're going to create another alternative.
我们应该认真考虑建造数百个全新的城市，挑选一个完全无人居住的地点说：我们要创造另一个选择。
This is Paul Romer. He's another big thinker in a very different country, the United States. But he basically came to the same conclusion as Octavio. Poor countries need a clean slate. Paul didn't call it a dot. He called it a charter city, kind of like a charter school, which gets to make its own rules and doesn't have to do what every other school in town is doing. And in Paul's model, a poor country would actually invite a rich country-- a Canada, say, or a Norway-- to come in with new laws, new courts, and help run the charter city.
这就是保罗·罗默（Paul Romer）。他是另一个在非常不同的国家——美国——的伟大思想家。但他基本上得出了和奥克塔维奥相同的结论。贫穷的国家需要一张白纸。保罗没叫它“圆点”。他叫它“特许城市”，有点像特许学校，它可以制定自己的规则，不必做镇上其他所有学校都在做的事。在保罗的模型中，一个贫穷的国家实际上会邀请一个富裕的国家——比如加拿大或挪威——进来，带着新法律、新法院，帮助运营特许城市。
So where Octavio's problem was that nobody took his idea seriously, Paul didn't have that problem. He's one of the most famous economists working today. People take him very seriously. And many people were seriously offended by his latest idea.
所以，奥克塔维奥的问题是没人把他的想法当回事，而保罗没有那个问题。他是当今最著名的经济学家之一。人们非常认真地对待他。而且许多人被他最新的这个想法深深冒犯了。
It didn't go over very well with me.
我对此感觉不太好。
This is Angus Deaton. He's an economist at Princeton.
这是安格斯·迪顿（Angus Deaton）。他是普林斯顿大学的经济学家。
I mean, I remember being surprised. I mean, he was advocating a reintroduction of colonialism. So I don't approve of it. I think it's a terrible idea.
我是说，我记得我很惊讶。我是说，他是在倡导殖民主义的回归。所以我并不赞成。我认为这是一个糟糕的主意。
Colonialism. You have this rich country coming in and bringing its rules into a poor country, sounds like the definition of colonialism
殖民主义。你有一个富裕的国家进来，把它的规则带到一个贫穷的国家，听起来这就是殖民主义的定义。
Paul insists it is not colonialism if a poor country is asking for help, if a poor country is inviting a rich country to come in and help set up a new city. But Paul was having a hard time finding a poor country to sign up for this.
保罗坚持认为，如果一个贫穷的国家在寻求帮助，如果一个贫穷的国家邀请一个富裕的国家进来帮助建立一个新的城市，那就不是殖民主义。但保罗很难找到一个愿意签署这个协议的贫穷国家。
Paul Romer may be known as a brilliant thinker, but he's not much of a salesman. For this to work, he needed to appeal to people's idealism and sense of hope, which is hard for Paul. It's just not in his nature. He told us, I'm a guy who  has a hard time understanding these things called "emotions" people seem to experience.
保罗·罗默可能被称为聪明的思想家，但他不是什么好的推销员。为了实现这一点，他需要诉诸人们的理想主义和希望感，这对保罗来说很难。这根本不是他的天性。他告诉我们：我是一个很难理解人们似乎经历的这些所谓的“情绪”的人。
I've been accused of being like Spock in Star Trek .
我曾被指责像《星际迷航》里的史波克（Spock）。
Paul Romer has devoted his life to making charter cities happen. He spent years flying around the world, talking to any finance minister or college kid who would listen. He was sure he just needed to let more people know he had a solution to global poverty. He just needed a way to package his charter cities idea, make it sound, OK, a little out there, but also maybe brilliant.
保罗·罗默致力于实现特许城市。他花了几年时间飞遍世界，与任何愿意倾听的财政部长或大学生交谈。他确信他只需要让更多人知道他有一个解决全球贫困的方案。他只是需要一种包装他的特许城市想法的方法，让它听起来：好吧，有点出格，但也许也很出色。
I decided that we needed to read conceptualize how we thought about economic development.
我决定我们需要重新构思我们对经济发展的思考方式。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And so Paul turned to the place our culture looks to hear world-changing ideas in easy-to-digest, Facebook-friendly 18-minute packages, TED talks. If you've never seen a TED talk, they're these public lectures you can watch on YouTube. Paul nailed it. It is everything a TED talk aspires to-- there are emotional hooks, there are graphs, there's data bouncing across the screen, jokes, there's an African child named Nelson studying under streetlights because his inept government can't get its act together to provide electricity. And by the end of the talk, Paul Romer has outlined an answer to the problems of the developing world. With the help of the TED producers, it sounds nothing like colonialism.
于是保罗转向了我们文化中寻找听取改变世界想法的地方，以易于消化、对Facebook友好的18分钟包装呈现——TED演讲。如果你从未看过TED演讲，它们是可以在YouTube上观看的公开讲座。保罗成功了。它是TED演讲所渴望的一切——有情感挂钩，有图表，有在屏幕上跳动的数据，有笑话，还有一个名叫纳尔逊（Nelson）的非洲孩子，因为他无能的政府无法提供电力，只能在路灯下学习。演讲结束时，保罗·罗默概述了解决发展中国家问题的答案。在TED制作人的帮助下，它听起来一点也不像殖民主义。
Then we can keep moving progress forward and truly make the world a better place, so that people like Nelson and his friends don't have to study any longer under the streetlights. Thank you.
然后我们可以继续推动进步，真正使世界变得更美好，这样像纳尔逊和他的朋友们就不必再在路灯下学习了。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Paul told us he hoped this talk would be like a message in a bottle. It worked. In 2010, the message washed up in the Honduran presidential palace in the office of Octavio Sanchez. The guy who wrote that nerdy novel when he was 16 years old was now chief of staff to the president. And when he saw the video, he knew Paul Romer was the key to making his idea happen in Honduras, a fancy world-renowned intellectual who would say to Octavio's fellow citizens, this is a good idea. And Hondurans, Octavio thought, would listen to this guy.
保罗告诉我们，他希望这次演讲能像漂流瓶里的信息一样。它奏效了。2010年，这个信息冲到了洪都拉斯总统府奥克塔维奥·桑切斯的办公室。那个16岁时写过呆板小说的人现在是总统的幕僚长。当他看到视频时，他知道保罗·罗默是让他的想法在洪都拉斯实现的关键——一位花哨的、世界知名的知识分子，他会告诉奥克塔维奥的同胞：这是一个好主意。奥克塔维奥认为，洪都拉斯人会听这个人的。
So just a few months after he saw the TED talk, Octavio managed to get Paul Romer and the president of Honduras together in a conference room in Miami. Paul made his economic case for the charter city, laid out all his graphs and data, but people in the room didn't seem that excited.
所以在他看到TED演讲仅几个月后，奥克塔维奥就设法让保罗·罗默和洪都拉斯总统在迈阿密的一个会议室见面。保罗提出了他的特许城市经济论点，展示了他所有的图表和数据，但房间里的人似乎并没有那么兴奋。
I was explaining kind of the details about how you could finance the city and the revenue stream for the government, and so forth. And then somebody said to me, Paul, why don't you just show your TED talk?
我正在解释关于你如何资助城市以及政府的收入流等等细节。然后有人对我说：保罗，你为什么不直接放你的TED演讲呢？
Because you were being too much of your Spock self?
因为你表现得太像史波克了？
Yeah. And so I sat down in the audience and then watched the TED talk with everybody else.
是啊。所以我坐在观众席上，和其他人一起看了那个TED演讲。
Watched yourself give a TED talk.
看着你自己做了一场TED演讲。
Yeah. And so I remember this woman who had just a little bit of a tear in her eye after she had watched this, and felt like this might actually make a difference in our country, this might work.
是啊。我记得当时那个女人看完之后眼睛里有一点泪水，觉得这可能真的会在我们的国家带来改变，这可能会起作用。
The president of Honduras told Paul that in order to do this, in order to completely erase Honduran law in one little corner of the country, we would have to change our constitution. So let's do it. Let's do it next month.
洪都拉斯总统告诉保罗，为了做到这一点，为了彻底消除洪都拉斯在国家一个小角落的法律，我们必须修改我们的宪法。那么我们做吧。下个月就做。
The Hondurans moved much more quickly than I expected. And so it was a little bit of a challenge, just racing to keep up with them. I thought it might be 10 years before some government would actually do something like pass a constitutional amendment or--
洪都拉斯人的行动比我预期的快得多。所以这是一个小小的挑战，只是要赶上他们。我以为某个政府可能需要10年时间才会真正做点什么，比如通过宪法修正案或者——
And here's the president of a country saying, we want to do it next month.
这就是一个国家的总统说：我们想下个月就做。
Yeah.
是啊。
Honduras was about to create a brand-new city.
洪都拉斯即将建立一个全新的城市。
Remember that spot that's just a dot on a map? A few months ago, we went there. It's not far from the Caribbean. It's very pretty and lush, palm trees. We were there with a guy named Carlos Pineda. He's a Honduran official who's trying to make this city happen. Although standing there, what we were looking at was the opposite of a city.
还记得地图上那个只是一个点的地点吗？几个月前，我们去了那里。它离加勒比海不远。那里非常漂亮和葱郁，有棕榈树。我们和一位名叫卡洛斯·皮内达（Carlos Pineda）的人一起在那儿。他是一位试图让这座城市成为现实的洪都拉斯官员。虽然站在那里，我们看到的却是城市的对立面。
It's just a valley with huge expansions of land, scattered trees, and a lot of green.
那只是一个有着巨大土地延伸的山谷，零星的树木，还有很多绿色。
To the Hondurans, it seemed surprisingly easy. As soon as they connected with Paul Romer, things moved really fast. The Honduran Congress changed the constitution. And now here's an actual piece of land. Paul transformed what was some weird local idea into the next big thing in global development. It was exciting.
对于洪都拉斯人来说，这似乎出奇地容易。一旦他们与保罗·罗默建立联系，事情进展得很快。洪都拉斯国会修改了宪法。现在这里有一块真正的土地。保罗将一个怪异的当地想法转变成了全球发展的下一个重大事件。这很令人兴奋。
Just getting to the dot, we could see the problems these guys are trying to solve. There's so much violent crime in the area that we were told to hire private security just to drive here. And we passed factories where people who are lucky enough to have jobs at all work at low-wage jobs, like sewing together fabric for t-shirts.
刚到那个点，我们就看到了这些人试图解决的问题。该地区的暴力犯罪太多，以至于我们被告知雇佣私人安保人员才能开车到这里。我们经过了工厂，那里有幸有工作的人从事低工资的工作，比如为T恤缝制布料。
But Carlos says this city is going to change all of that. He says, just imagine.
但卡洛斯说这座城市将改变这一切。他说，试想一下。
I'm seeing a lot of people, particularly young people with children, parks, lots of trees. And I see office buildings and condos and beach condos and hotels and coffee shops and restaurants. And roads, lots of roads.
我看到了很多人，特别是带着孩子的年轻人，公园，许多树木。我看到了办公大楼和公寓、海滨公寓、酒店和咖啡馆以及餐厅。还有道路，许多道路。
All this will happen, Carlos says, because this city is going to have totally different rules than the rest of Honduras. It's not just going to be another free trade zone or a place with some special labor laws. The dream is to create all the institutions of civil society-- decent schools where teachers get paid and kids learn to read, honest cops, functioning courts. They might copy laws from other places. When we were there, we heard a lot of talk about Texas state law, which is apparently pro-business. They might hire retired judges from other countries-- say, the UK.
卡洛斯说，所有这些都会发生，因为这座城市将拥有与洪都拉斯其他地方完全不同的规则。它不仅仅是另一个自由贸易区或拥有一些特殊劳动法的地方。梦想是创造所有的公民社会机构——体面的学校，老师得到报酬，孩子们学会阅读；诚实的警察；运作良好的法院。他们可能会复制其他地方的法律。我们去的时候，听到了很多关于德克萨斯州法律的讨论，显然它是亲商业的。他们可能会雇佣来自其他国家的退休法官——比如英国。
And at the beginning, the money to pay for these things would be largely from foreign companies coming in and building factories and offices in the new city. But eventually, Carlos says, the city would be full of young entrepreneurs and tech startups owned by Hondurans.
起初，支付这些费用的钱将主要来自外国公司进来在新城市建立工厂和办公室。但卡洛斯说，最终，这座城市将充满属于洪都拉斯人的年轻企业家和科技初创公司。
No, I don't see a lot of suits. In my view, it has to be a fairly cool place to live.
不，我没看到很多西装。在我看来，它必须是一个相当酷的居住地。
I lived in Seattle for a while. It sounds like you're describing Seattle.
我在西雅图住过一段时间。听起来你在描述西雅图。
Yeah. It sounds reasonable, yeah. Hopefully is.
是啊。听起来很合理，是的。希望如此。
Seattle and Honduras.
西雅图和洪都拉斯。
Yes. Hopefully, yes, it will be something like that. I can see how it wouldn't be believable right now. But I can tell you that it can happen.
是的。希望如此，是的，它会像那样。我能理解为什么现在听起来不可信。但我可以告诉你，它是有可能发生的。
They started planning to build this new city. There was a flood of excitement, and then things started to get rocky. The dot needed a court system. And after months and months, they were still debating what exactly that should look like. The dot needed foreign investors, and the investors weren't coming in as quickly as everyone had hoped. And when the Hondurans and Paul sat down to actually try and iron out the details to work together, that, it turned out, was challenging. Carlos Pineda, the guy who took us to the dot, says Paul's attitude was hard to take. He says, we invited this guy here to help us, but he wasn't acting like a helper.
他们开始计划建造这座新城市。起初充满了兴奋，然后事情开始变得艰难。那个圆点需要一个法院系统。几个月又几个月过去了，他们仍在辩论那到底应该是什么样子。圆点需要外国投资者，而投资者并没有像每个人希望的那样快地进来。当洪都拉斯人和保罗坐下来真正尝试协调细节以合作时，事实证明，那是具有挑战性的。带我们去那个点的卡洛斯·皮内达说，保罗的态度让人难以接受。他说，我们邀请这个人来帮助我们，但他表现得不像个帮手。
So he wanted to have full control of everything that happened. For instance, if some foreign journalist wanted to interview me or interview Octavio, I would right away get an email saying his advice, sometimes unwanted. OK, you have to be careful. This guy comes from such magazine or so. I mean, we have an idea of how things work.
所以他想完全控制发生的一切。例如，如果某个外国记者想采访我或采访奥克塔维奥，我会立刻收到一封邮件，说他的建议，有时是不受欢迎的。好吧，你必须小心。这家伙来自某某杂志之类的。我是说，我们知道事情是如何运作的。
Or Paul would tell the Hondurans about how they should structure the court system in some particular way. And the Hondurans weren't so interested, but Paul would go ahead and set up meetings for them anyway.
或者保罗会告诉洪都拉斯人他们应该如何以某种特定方式构建法院系统。洪都拉斯人并不太感兴趣，但保罗无论如何都会继续为他们安排会议。
Keep in mind, this is a Honduran project. It's done by the Honduran government, and it was mostly designed by Hondurans.
记住，这是一个洪都拉斯项目。它由洪都拉斯政府完成，而且大部分由洪都拉斯人设计。
But journalists from all over the world loved the story of the famous academic who got the chance to try his idea in a real live country. Octavio Sanchez had been dreaming about this idea long before he met Paul Romer. And he says the Hondurans did not expect their story to be told this way, with their country essentially reduced to serving as a Petri dish for a North American plan.
但世界各地的记者都喜欢那个著名的学者有机会在现实中尝试他的想法的故事。奥克塔维奥·桑切斯在遇到保罗·罗默之前很久就在梦想这个想法了。他说，洪都拉斯人没想到他们的故事会被这样讲述，他们的国家基本上被贬低为仅仅是一个作为北美计划的培养皿。
The only thing that got out of Honduras was how Paul Romer had convinced the Honduran government to build the charter city. I spent hours speaking with journalists, and the only thing that comes out is Romer, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, for pages, for pages, and then the small quote in the end. And the reaction from the Honduran government is the following one.
从洪都拉斯传出去的唯一事情就是保罗·罗默如何说服洪都拉斯政府建立特许城市。我花了几个小时与记者交谈，唯一传出来的就是“罗默，blah，blah，blah，blah，blah”，好几页，好几页，最后只有一小段引用。而洪都拉斯政府的反应是以下这一点。
At the beginning, Octavio brought in Paul to help sell this plan in Honduras. And it worked. They sold it. But now it seemed to Octavio like Paul was poisoning the project. Accomplishing even small things became very difficult.
起初，奥克塔维奥请来保罗帮助推销这个计划。而且奏效了。他们推销出去了。但现在在奥克塔维奥看来，保罗正在毒害这个项目。完成即使是小事情也变得非常困难。
No one in the cabinet or around me wanted to help in this idea if Romer was involved. I had an empathy with him, and I was willing to defend him. And I was willing to get things done if he thought that they were useful for the project. The fact is that, what I told you, it was like I was hitting a wall. When I tried to do things with him here, at some point in time, no one was willing to help.
内阁或我周围没有人想在罗默参与的情况下帮助这个想法。我和他有共鸣，我愿意为他辩护。如果他认为对项目有用，我愿意把事情办成。事实是，正如我告诉你的，就好像我在撞墙。当我试着在这里和他一起做事情时，在某个时间点，没有人愿意帮忙。
The Hondurans' complaints about Paul Romer and about the foreign press, they seem kind of petty. I mean, you're talking about fixing your whole country here. Who cares what a story in The Economist says? Who cares if Paul Romer is lacking in social graces? Suck it up. Save your country. But remember, the phrase "banana republic" was invented to describe Honduras. US-based fruit companies were hugely powerful here for a big chunk of the 20th century. At one point, one company even funded a coup to overthrow the government. Before that, there were hundreds of years of Spanish colonialism.
洪都拉斯人对保罗·罗默和外国媒体的抱怨，看起来有点琐碎。我是说，你们在这里谈论的是修理整个国家。谁在乎《经济学人》的一篇文章怎么说？谁在乎保罗·罗默是否缺乏社交礼仪？忍忍吧。拯救你们的国家。但记住，“香蕉共和国”这个词就是为了描述洪都拉斯而发明的。美国的水果公司在20世纪的大部分时间里在这里极其强大。有一次，一家公司甚至资助了一场政变以推翻政府。在此之前，有几百年的西班牙殖民统治。
All of this sent a clear message to Honduras. North Americans, the whole rich world, they don't think you're up to running your own country. So all this petty stuff is just not petty in Honduras. It really matters when a story in The Economist says a Honduran idea is actually some brilliant plan imposed by a North American economist. Here's Octavio.
所有这些向洪都拉斯传达了一个明确的信息。北美，整个富裕的世界，他们不认为你们有能力运营自己的国家。所以所有这些琐碎的事情在洪都拉斯根本不琐碎。当《经济学人》的一篇文章说一个洪都拉斯的想法实际上是由一位北美经济学家强加的绝妙计划时，这真的很重要。这是奥克塔维奥。
Many people all over the world don't understand that we are poor not because we are dumb. We are poor because of our institutional arrangement, not because we lack the capacity to imagine things.
世界上很多人不明白，我们贫穷不是因为我们愚蠢。我们贫穷是因为我们的制度安排，而不是因为我们缺乏想象事物的能力。
In Honduras, public opinion turned against the plan. And a group of lawyers challenged the project in the country's supreme court.
在洪都拉斯，公众舆论转向反对该计划。一群律师在该国的最高法院挑战了这个项目。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
This is Oscar Cruz. He's one of those lawyers. And he says charter cities violate the country's sovereignty. They violate the fundamental rights of all Hondurans.
这是奥斯卡·克鲁兹（Oscar Cruz）。他是那些律师之一。他说特许城市侵犯了国家主权。它们侵犯了所有洪都拉斯人的基本权利。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] Paul Romer.
[西班牙语] 保罗·罗默。
And he says they're being promoted by Paul Romer and some other North Americans who think they've discovered a magic formula to raise the world out of poverty.
他说，它们是由保罗·罗默和一些其他认为自己发现了让世界脱贫的魔法公式的北美人在推动。
Octavio's response to this is, yes, this new city would have many of its own laws, foreigners might be appointed as judges, but it would be run by a Honduran governor, not by some foreign country. He says the whole supreme court challenge is really just a big misunderstanding.
奥克塔维奥对此的回应是：是的，这座新城市将拥有许多自己的法律，外国人可能会被任命为法官，但它将由一位洪都拉斯总督管理，而不是由某个外国国家管理。他说，整个最高法院的挑战其实只是一个巨大的误解。
By the middle of 2012, the project is starting to stall, and Paul is part of the problem. But Octavio never says that to Paul directly.
到2012年中期，项目开始停滞，保罗是问题的一部分。但奥克塔维奥从未直接对保罗说这些。
So Paul moves ahead. He thinks he's on this commission that's supposed to oversee the new Honduran city. And he goes around the world trying to get powerful people to sign on. He even gets a Nobel Prize-winner.
所以保罗继续前进。他认为自己在这个应该监督新洪都拉斯城市的委员会里。他飞遍世界试图让有权势的人签约。他甚至找到了一个诺贝尔奖得主。
In Honduras, meanwhile, they're dragging their feet on making this commission official. But Paul's understanding is that he should press on anyway.
与此同时在洪都拉斯，他们在使这个委员会正式化方面拖拖拉拉。但保罗的理解是，他无论如何都应该继续推进。
And then one day last summer, Paul is in Sweden talking to IKEA about building housing for a charter city, a million apartments or something. And he reads in the news that Honduras has signed a deal with some group of investors. Paul doesn't know anything about it. He's stunned.
然后去年夏天的一天，保罗在瑞典与宜家谈论为特许城市建造住房，什么一百万套公寓之类的事。然后他在新闻里读到，洪都拉斯已经与某家投资集团签署了协议。保罗对此一无所知。他惊呆了。
There was an announcement in the newspapers, that we heard about in the newspapers, that the government had signed some kind of agreement with a private firm. I mean, I got email, press inquiries. This is wonderful. The thing is taking off. Your idea is taking off. And I don't know who this firm is. I don't know who's backing it. I don't know what their plan is.
报纸上有个公告，我们是从报纸上听到的，政府已经与一家私人公司签署了某种协议。我是说，我收到了电子邮件，新闻询问。这太棒了。事情正在起飞。你的想法正在起飞。而我不知道这家公司是谁。我不知道是谁在支持它。我不知道他们的计划是什么。
Paul thinks that, as a member of the commission-- which, by the way, is called the Transparency Commission-- his job is to review these kind of deals, to make sure nothing shady is going on. So Paul calls Octavio, and he asks him--
保罗认为，作为委员会的一员——顺便说一下，那个委员会叫透明委员会——他的工作是审查这类交易，确保没有见不得光的事情发生。所以保罗打电话给奥克塔维奥，他问他——
Can I see the agreement?
我能看协议吗？
No, we can't show you that, because there is no legal grounds to show you that.
不，我们不能给你看那个，因为没有法律依据给你看那个。
They said that it's protected by a non-disclosure agreement and they couldn't show it to me.
他们说它受到保密协议的保护，他们不能给我看。
But I'm a member of the Transparency Commission. No, you aren't. Then are you saying that I'm not? No, there's no Transparency Commission.
但我是一名透明委员会成员。不，你不是。那么你是说我不是？不，没有透明委员会。
And so I just knew at that moment.
所以我在那一刻就知道了。
It was over. They talked one more time after that. Paul told Octavio he was resigning from the commission. Octavio told Paul there was nothing for him to resign from. And the next month, the Honduran supreme court ruled the project unconstitutional. The dot was dead.
结束了。在那之后他们又谈了一次。保罗告诉奥克塔维奥他要辞去委员会的职务。奥克塔维奥告诉保罗，他没什么可辞职的。下个月，洪都拉斯最高法院裁定该项目违宪。那个圆点死了。
So the question is, could this big, ambitious idea actually have worked if things had been a little different in Honduras? You could definitely imagine if Paul Romer were different, if he were better with people, was a little more sensitive to politics and who gets credit, things would have gone differently. And maybe they'd be building a brand-new city in Honduras right now, at least that's what Octavio and Carlos told us.
所以问题是，如果洪都拉斯的情况稍微不同一点，这个宏大、雄心勃勃的想法实际上能行得通吗？你绝对可以想象，如果保罗·罗默不同，如果他更擅长与人相处，对政治和谁获得功劳更敏感一点，事情会有所不同。也许他们现在已经在洪都拉斯建造一座全新的城市了，至少这就是奥克塔维奥和卡洛斯告诉我们的。
We ran this by Paul. And by the way, it's not easy to say to someone, they just didn't like you. We told Paul it started to seem to the Hondurans like you were bossing them around and taking all the credit. Paul says if that's what this is about, that's ridiculous.
我们将此告诉了保罗。顺便说一下，要对某人说“他们就是不喜欢你”并不容易。我们告诉保罗，在洪都拉斯人看来，你开始像是在对他们发号施令并抢占所有功劳。保罗说，如果事情是关于这个的，那太荒谬了。
If hurt feelings over those kind of things are what killed this whole project, that's just such an amazing tragedy. All this other stuff about hurt feelings and who gets credit and all that other stuff should be set aside, and all of the attention has to be focused on, what can we do that works? And what's disappointing, and I think really tragic, is that that isn't what happened here. Then as an outsider, all I can do is go find another country to go work with.
如果因这类事情而产生的受伤感情是杀死整个项目的原因，那真是太悲剧了。所有关于受伤感情、谁获得功劳以及所有其他事情都应该被搁置，所有的注意力都必须集中在：我们能做什么行得通的事情？令人失望的是，我认为真正悲剧的是，这里发生的事情并非如此。然后作为一个局外人，我唯一能做的就是去找另一个国家合作。
Paul told us that in the next country he finds, he'll pretty much handle himself the way he did in Honduras, which, I got to say, makes it hard to see how he'll get different results.
保罗告诉我们，在他找到的下一个国家，他基本上会像在洪都拉斯那样行事，我不得不说，这让人很难看出他会如何得到不同的结果。
But no matter who is promoting this project, no matter how politically sensitive or savvy they are, this is always going to be a long shot. I mean, what government anywhere doesn't care about ego and who gets credit? What government is going to be willing to overturn its own laws and go up against entrenched interests? It's just hard to imagine this really working out. But Octavio, like Paul, is still optimistic. Despite everything, he still believes one of these cities is going to happen.
但无论谁在推动这个项目，无论他们对政治多么敏感或精明，这始终是一个冒险的尝试。我是说，哪里有什么政府不在乎自我和谁获得功劳？有什么政府愿意推翻自己的法律并与根深蒂固的利益集团作对？真的很难想象这会真的成功。但奥克塔维奥和保罗一样，仍然很乐观。尽管有这一切，他仍然相信这些城市中的一个终会发生。
There will be a country that will adopt it. I'm more than positive that this will happen somewhere. I don't know where. And it will be a success. And when people see that happening somewhere else in the world, I think that that will be followed by many countries all over the developing world.
会有一个国家采用它的。我完全确信这会发生在某个地方。我不知道在哪里。而且它会成功。当人们看到它在世界其他地方发生时，我想这之后会有许多发展中国家的许多国家跟进。
Octavio's best hope for that right now is probably Paul Romer. Paul is back on the road. He says he's got a lead in North Africa.
奥克塔维奥目前对此最大的希望可能是保罗·罗默。保罗又在路上了。他说他在北非找到了线索。
Chana Joffee-Walt and Jacob Goldstein from Planet Money , which is a co-production of NPR News and our program. To get their free-- free-- podcast and their blog, with economic reporting that actually makes sense and is listenable, go to npr.org/money.
来自《星球财富》（Planet Money）的查娜·乔夫-沃尔特和雅各布·戈德斯坦，这是NPR新闻和我们节目的联合制作。要获取他们免费——免费——的播客和博客，以及真正讲得通且可听的经济报告，请访问npr.org/money。
[MUSIC - "UTOPIA" BY RUBY CUBE]
[音乐 - Ruby Cube的《乌托邦》]
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Tarek Fouda. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddis.
好吧，我们的节目今天由萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与制作。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塔雷克·福达（Tarek Fouda）提供制作帮助。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。艾丽斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。音乐帮助来自达米恩·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗布·盖迪斯（Rob Geddis）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where we link to our completely redesigned Android app, thisamericanlife.org. You can also get that on Google Play, and of course we have apps for iPhone and iPad. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he guest-taught a journalism class this week and told them what you need to include in any successful radio story.
我们的网站，我们在上面链接到我们完全重新设计的Android应用：thisamericanlife.org。你也可以在Google Play上获取它，当然我们也有适用于iPhone和iPad的应用。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。你知道，他本周客座教授了一个新闻课，并告诉他们成功广播故事需要包含什么。
Breast.
乳房。
A breast.
一个乳房。
Breast.
乳房。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "UTOPIA" BY RUBY CUBE]
[音乐 - Ruby Cube的《乌托邦》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。